all right we're here today you've got so
much going on as always one of the
things is that now we can all have our
own Warwick car we tell me about that
yeah you can you can have Warwick in
your pocket basically in a formal pocket
Warwick he's somebody who inhabits your
electronic handheld device be it an
iPhone an iPad or an Android device so
so yeah I kind of had conquered the the
big screen the small screen and now
hopefully the touchscreen it really
raved about it where did the idea come
from it came from my love of my phone
basically something I always have with
me at all times and and also my love of
performance and I thought how can I
combine these two things and you know
would it be great to be able to kind of
get inside a phone and and that's kind
of how that the idea sort of was formed
was the idea of you know me actually
physically living in the phone and you
have to look after me and and you know
feed me and make sure I'm entertained
and happy and educated at the same time
send me off for auditions so the real
the real game play comes into effect
when you have to get me from a said list
celebrity all the way up to an a-list
at which point you earn a lot more money
for the jobs that you do and then can
buy better items and redecorate
Warwick's little environment within the
poem of the auditions and some of the
roles that you can get in the in the
game they're all in the back of my
t-shirt well a lot of them are and I
wrote them but none will come to me now
we've got small runnings we have got
yeah knee-high ninja there's another one
I mean there's a lot of play on on words
kind of as far as the older heights goes
but there's also other titles which
really don't mean anything like skeletal
mass the glow of nothing I mean these
are all films that I think should be
made and I may well go and make them
after this another thing you've been
making at the moment is a news show with
karl Pilkington isn't it what kind of
traveling companion is he
karl is a unique individual he he moans
just as much as you would imagine I
spent five weeks with the man and I
don't know how I came out of it sane but
this time he's got not only where we are
and what we're doing to mode about as
he's always had but he's also got me to
moan about and to moan too so yo fam I
imagine it was heaven but yeah after
five weeks it does your head in
but yeah so you you you get to see my
exploits with him on sky1 starting late
November but yeah I didn't saw things I
never thought I'd see in a long time it
was that kind of places you go to and
what's your favorite memory from it well
we took a trip from from Venice Italy
retracing the steps of Marco Polo all
the way across India and China and
finishing in Hong Kong I can already
tell you too much about what we saw at
this point but yeah they were there were
pretty unique experiences I'm not saying
definitely tuning in to find out a
little bit more about that way and then
something else you also Dan is life -
sure
or is it like working with Ricky Gervais
and Stephen Merchant and I believe
you've got a special of that coming up
haven't you Ricky and Stephen of course
rightly so of won awards because they
are both brilliant writer directors and
and they were they were fantastic too
I mean so conscientious but at the same
time so sure of what they wanted that we
moved through a day smelling very very
quickly would often finish by about 4
o'clock so you know as an actor that's
lovely because then I could go back to
the hotel or back home and learn what we
needed for the next day because we're
getting through vast amounts of material
in a day and I'm in everything so
there's really no time unless you just
keep a head on the scripts but they're
brilliant and the special is amazing we
film that next year and it's fantastic
scripts in terms of cameos of causes to
show there has a lot of cameos in it
isn't it you have some great ones what
were your favorites and what maybe can
we look forward to next year Johnny Depp
brilliant man lovely man as well we had
such fun Liam Neeson probably one of
people's favorites cameos I mean
brilliant scene the stand-up comedy
scene
Helen it was terrific I mean I loved
that scene particularly because he
really does demonstrate that kind of
hierarchy within the film industry if
you don't know it you know there's such
a difference between being a background
actor or standing by the way I'm through
to the star it's a vast difference and a
hierarchy I think was really really
brought out in in that particular
episode in which Warwick thinks he's
going to be starring alongside muscles
his way in to gain the job at the
expense of some of his own client but
but then realizes he's only doubling for
a child it's it's absolute genius I
can't tell you anything about the the
cameo in the next series because yeah
it's brilliant but it's top secret but
it is really really really fitting as
well that's great such a tease well I
know you've got some movies coming up as
well Jack the giant slayer that's kind
of all wrapped now but tell me a little
bit about your role in that
you know I can barely remember it
because we filmed it such a long time
ago
and I'm only just getting used to
calling it Jack the giant slayer now but
yeah I play a guy that works in a in a
traveling show and no we have a show
that's that's that's running right at
the beginning of a movie basically I
can't tell you anymore immensely I don't
think I also short fellows is something
else that you're working on isn't it
tell me about that well I wish I was but
it's a script at the moment it's a great
concept we've got a class but we don't
have the money for it so you know we're
trying to really get the budget together
I mean every film has its time and I
just don't feel it's the right time for
this film at the moment so we just kind
of holy crap there's a lot and things
like that they're just sitting
development for a long time and then
suddenly become a reality so so yet
nothing happening on that front at the
moment keep our eyes open for it what
can we look forward from you next we got
the Idiot Abroad specials I'm shooting a
documentary for ITV about Auschwitz that
will be on next March but they've been
doing that at the moment couple of the
top-secret projects they're very
exciting and I'm sure your viewers will
be interested in but I can't tell you
anything about them I spend most of my
life not being here to say stuff it's
it's lovely that we finished Harry
Potter now because I can tell you
everything but there was always a time
when I couldn't say and yeah I have two
things that I can't talk about I'm also
just about to launch another company
called the signature shop which will be
selling exclusive license to marry poor
items a lot of sign things so that
launch is very soon as well welcome
people look out for that at the
signature shop code at UK but it's not
quite there yet we're about to launch
you know within the next couple of weeks
as you'd imagine and finally your Spago
free as well we shouldn't because I
mention obviously tell me what was the
highlight when you're writing it and
looking back on your career so far
I was fascinating Ryan Evert because I
realized how many things are done I
don't think we always appreciate
everything we've done in life or
achieved and sitting down to write the
book I didn't really think about my life
and though that was a really good
experience wow it's really lucky to have
done that and you know I recommend to
everybody you know don't necessary to
book but do to do make a few notes of
what you've done during a day because it
mainly makes you think about it
and takes top of what you've done and
it's good to look back on as well so it
was a really rewarding experience and
it's lovely when you come to an event
like this and you know everypony is
buying the book I mean it's it's amazing
there I mean it's been out a couple of
years now but still it seems if not more
popular than ever now all kind of things
you get people asking you about in
particular when they come to these
events at the moment they're asking me
what's karl Pilkington like is he really
like that yes they say is Simon from the
Yogscast really like that yes
they what do they ask me what else
what's the record rates like it's always
what what you know these people
sometimes have a bit of a persona and
they're kind of mysterious and you know
people want to know what they're like I
guess yeah and it was it hotter than
Ewok costume obvious question I would
have thought but nonetheless one that is
ass
you